scp-682 the indestructible reptile  versus  scp-3519 a dangerous memetic contagion  responsible for killing nearly the  entire population of the world in a  certain timeline scp-3519 infected  global media to influence the public  into believing that the world would end  on march 5th 2019. group of foundation  personnel decided to test 3519's  exposure with 682 in hopes that it might  terminate the lizard once and for all  lowering the acid levels inside its tank  682 was exposed to the contagion but did  not show any self-destructive ideation  instead 682 nightmarishly laughed for  193 seconds before it was placed back  into containment after march 5th there  was only one lone human survivor junior  researcher dr rory jones when 682  encountered the doctor after breaching  containment it did not kill him instead  it simply stated we are like now meat  killing you would only end suffering